back atcha boy psychobabble playing the
hair steal for it it's pretty early in
the morning [ __ ] outside what's up to
our necks Kinsey why you something
dedicated to finding information dad
cargo plane being escorted in skill for
hair straightener no that's something I
can work with you're welcome viola get
her plane ready yet again I an say hail
attacking thing
now the sides right cat
no I want to do found love tap this
really pretty good oh [ __ ] I can't get
well this was all these restricts
ezell's jasus
look at saints had good [ __ ]
beautiful [ __ ] him yet a volley I'm out
I'm saying
a lot of flying this game ok come on I
was there that was that
I
yet again
no doubt no parachute this person
okay good
ok dress for any action
they say say
pilots have the door locked here in a
supply plane for the military there has
to be something you can use al garden is
a cargo the gunfire isn't tipping you
off will there be any problems getting
to the cockpit yeah these people really
topped it
that's oh forgot is important try to
actually stay in the plane man these
favor really really tough you can't grab
either what's in that this thing won't
get the job done there anything else to
try
says I don't even know what this is okay
okay okay okay that's it oh yeah let
them in here here we go some high-tech
weapon thing hey music so we can land
these things already this is mine
training using oh [ __ ] don't know what
the [ __ ] this is
at least you're inside
Oh what is this
wasn't too much for you hey like AB
literates though
something wrong here Oh God asset gone
what do you mean gone this is great
listen think it was like no time oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] in 38 seconds
turbulence shut
[ __ ] us everywhere
dammit I'm good
that's what I would
Oh God yet I'm gonna regret this just
[ __ ] inside it's like the beginning
good girls kick ass
how do you get handling exactly [ __ ] a
yeah is it like exactly a fly right
bottom Jesus
oh yeah here you go
Jesus insurance on this thing is that
this slider place
you
Wow walk through the air again who's
that
okay to hit the ground Wow
chef
catgut
nothing ridiculous yeah still falling
okay okay what else is there
should be first
why would I
by always recording this [ __ ]
the [ __ ] oh we're almost to the ground
great placement plane I can't let's [ __ ]
out of here okay still the tank that
[ __ ]
a lot of rubble Lana Roe this is why I
don't join NASA yeah I can't get good
I get in here and get in here don't lie
my just slip it in here
how did I survive or remember they don't
really don't leave i doubt that want to
be realistic guys see Elijah life not
shut it looks like pink ass what the
[ __ ] well [ __ ] zombies [ __ ] my life
what [ __ ] tosser yeah that's
disgusting
laughing
dips out for Harambee